what's up guys it's Wednesday februari
24th I'm Mary let's talk about some news
first up Stephan curry skills are off
the charts right now in fact he's so
good he's screwing up the balance in NBA
2k16 NBA 2k gameplay director Mike Wang
spoke to Forbes about how scoring in the
paint and three-point shooting are the
toughest areas to balance properly this
task gets even harder when you add
Stephan curry to the mix who beat out
his video game counterpart when ESPN s
2k sports to run simulations on the NBA
star the results show that real-life
Stephan curry is outperforming his
virtual self the real curry averages 20
9.8 points per game with 36 30 point
games and 388 three-pointers while the
video game curry only 28.5 points per
game with 23 30 point games and 293
3-pointers they nerfed curry Wang says
they're still not positive on how to
accurately represent him in NBA 2k games
without making him overwhelming to be
honest we're looking for ways the better
translate his game and NBA 2k he's a
rule breaker when it comes to jump
shooting he becomes a problem in the
video game world where we've been trying
to train our gamers to know what certain
types of shots should be rewarded versus
others I reached out to Shaquille O'Neal
for comment and he suggested that they
put JaVale McGee on the team to help
with balance our second story is that
there was a halo update today and we are
live with someone playing it right now
uh I was having fun but you sat in front
of the TV what's the update like it's
fun but again you're in front of the TV
I'm dying it it's not going let's hear
about that update halo 5 Guardians
expands again today with the release of
hammer storm the xbox one shooters
latest free update and that's not all
developer 343 also teased the game's
future expansions and content confirming
the fan favorite firefight mode and more
will be added in the future included
with hammer storm is a new arena map
that looks like a revolving Space
Station's called torque as well as new
weapons like the gravity hammer and
halo 1 era Magnum it also introduces the
Grifball multiplayer mode you remember
Grifball 343 also teased Taillow fives
upcoming DLC which will include
expansions called Gosa Meridian memories
of reach and hog wild additionally 343
confirmed that firefight mode is
returning it will be called war zone
firefight for now they're saying they're
gonna let players battle together
against common foes and truly show off
their custom Spartans to boot that's all
we know now what we will be revealing
more as we hear about it yesterday I
told you all the free games you get with
xbox gold and I even teens a free game
that you got with PlayStation Plus today
I'm giving you the whole PlayStation
Plus lift a total of six games are going
to be available including 24 playstation
4 ps4 users with a subscription pick up
bro force that's the one voted for fans
that told you about yesterday and galaxy
when the PlayStation Store refreshes in
March meanwhile the last guy and super
stardust HD will be offered on ps3 Vita
owners get to also they get flame over
and reality fighters now the current
slate of PS Plus games including nom nom
galaxy and grid Autosport are still
available until the new lineup on march
first you have until then to claim them
so that's it for today but be sure to
check back again tomorrow when we'll
have some more news yeah doesn't feel
very good with someone to stand in front
of you they're trying to work it's a
joke
you